[Music]
you are coaching your son's basketball
team is that right yes and i'm curious
because i have a six-year-old boy who is
now playing basketball and uh i go and i
try and give him tips what tips do you
give a young kid when you when you're
coaching them about basketball none
you don't give any tips no we just go
out and play and have a good time and i
have a
special defense a defense yes it's
called the rod defense so let's just say
i'm playing against your team and your
son and your son is a great dribbler
yeah i tell all my guys to do the ride
defense garage defenses all five guys
will run at your son and go
turn the ball over my team laid out
their way
that's horrifying
that's a horrifying experience
uh all right let me ask you about this
uh you are now an analyst okay uh and
you are analyzing other people's game on
television as a player you famously
hated it when commentators used to talk
about your game now you're on the other
side of it analyzing their game does
this make you react any differently to
being an analyst well i didn't really
hate it when commentators analyzed my
game i hated it when people that didn't
have the g14 classification analyze my
game
g14 classification yeah which means like
if you never played how can you talk
about how i play right it doesn't make
sense like if i'm listening and you
never played and you talk about somebody
else i don't really believe you so when
sports uh sportscasters who've never
played the game are there and they're
criticizing you so you feel that you're
not the old ones but like you know these
new guys
that you know just popped up in the last
five years guys who i've never heard of
who are so-called experts with no g14
classification i have g96 classification
this is a real classification g96
are you the only it sounds like a very
few people get a g96 obama has the g96
[Applause]
[Music]
uh all right i have to mention this very
quickly you're a spokesperson for dove
men plus care yes i'm very why dove of
all the products because because as we
all know i'm very comfortable in my own
skin
and that's their slogan and uh just love
life and it's a great product and helps
me smell good check it out
again
oh my goodness
it's fantastic
that you're going around going check
that out
that's dope they love it that i'm
comfortable in my own skin when you're
on skin i love that okay is that your
new slogans yes be comfortable in your
own skin yeah so charles burke
yeah